the gyro can experience what do you
think about this new trend that you're
seeing like you saw it particularly
coming out of John Danaher and Dean
Lister with leg locks like leg locks are
so big in jujitsu competition now when
when we learn jujitsu yesterday we would
not learn anything related to legs until
we get our blue belt the main reason
behind these were to be able to let you
develop guard mm-hmm
would that concern anything just learn
how to move your hips in sweeps and
hooks foot lock is something very
effective but if I show you right away I
might be stopping some of the evolution
of your game or the other person that
you train with that he can learn which
will make even better his foot lock
right that's why we hold back until
people get a one-year chew into jujitsu
to learn leg locks but you do have the
noogie everybody's such in a hurry then
a lot of noogie schools the first thing
people wants to learn it I want to learn
heel hook mm-hmm and she cheats with G I
wanna learn armbar right the noogie
wants to go straight to the lag they get
people want to go straight to down but I
think particularly because of the the
success of these leg lockers against
high level competition no it's effective
is amazing I think it's a portion of the
game you know and I and you will see the
development of people that we have
defending that which also will force
guys to pass out so beyond the legs only
mm-hmm but definitely they work it's a
very dangerous let people wrap their
legs around your leg hook you there I
mean not everybody can get out of that
and if you don't tap you're gonna get
your knee ripped apart for sure and
that's the real problem with leg locks
is that so many guys wound up with
pretty devastating knee injuries in the
eighties the the the decision not to
have heel hooks in jiu-jitsu was for
safety we do we did practice but the
competition does not allowed you gotta
understand and in the eighties if you
have any problem your careers over right
there's no surgery that we really would
fit in exactly right today is different
yeah
you understand it's the evolution of the
medical side make possible for you to
put a brand new knee over there yeah but
still to this day meniscus tears and
cartilage tears those are still huge
mean without stem cells it's very very
difficult to fix those unless you get
when it's cute like I had part of my
meniscus removed on my left knee and
then you see them in you want to Train
fall on Jeopardy and you can understand
too is I think some of those things
should be kind of almost cranium a pearl
leaked into the digital world because a
lot of people they get hurt before even
they learn what you Jitsu is that's why
my only concern is the danger of all
those Hugh hooks leg locks because if
you get somebody who knows he might tap
or he might roll to the right side even
know a lot of guys to get hurt yeah but
if you hold somebody who doesn't have
much experience in one of those traps
it's for sure injury they brought the
wrong way and rip it apart themselves
even if you don't squeeze it's because
they don't know what you do right yeah
and my that's my view of as an
instructor today
on my school Synanon you're not ready
for legs yet right oh I go to the noogie
don't go to the noogie tournament yet
you have to learn first you understand
for your own safety and also I want them
to develop guard because when we get
hired with pool guard mmm
when you get tired you lie down to sleep
you don't sleep standing you sleep when
you lie down and you sheets is the same
thing you get tired you're gonna pull
guard and that's one of the ways I see
some of my students in the tournament
they get tired he's a top guy son hey
stop pulling guard then his tire he's
already most and that's why you have to
have a good guard just to survive and
rest to be able to continue we're
surprised though that this nogi leglock
games are taken off the way there I
think because of the success you have so
many guys doing extremely well
and some of the guys that came from the
nogi originally doing so well now some
of the guys that come from the gig world
doing Oggy they've been finding some
challenges to adjust to that lag I think
in a way you have Chuy's that simplify
because if you get somebody in a Foot
Locker like lot there we go and at the
same time you complicate because you see
a lot of scramble now and a lot of
injuries every day and the same people
don't want to tap then it's a position
that you something's gonna get hurt
yeah but I'm is that development and
evolution of the the grappling world and
I think it's amazing
sooner or later somebody's gonna find a
ways to protect better and better and
better and better they were forced
people to move on but you've seen that I
think now with a lot of leglock guys
against each other they're kind of
stalemate and you see them winning by
rear naked choke or armbar again they're
not using their leg locks against each
other right you realize like man he
knows as much as I do now I need more
than that yeah they're using them to
sweep or they use them to set up other
things they're trying to exploit other
holes like maybe they concentrate too
much on leg locks so then they they're
open to arm bars or chokes I remember
when when I learned in the beginning we
have foot lock eyes the last resource
let's see I'm fighting a guy in a man
I'm not able to submit him we're gonna
foot lock him mmm that's how we used to
have on the 80s Hail Mary what lock is
okay this is my deadly weapon if
everything that I do is not working I
laugh at lock him today is the opposite
my first shot is foot lock him all the
way he's not working I'm gonna choke him
yeah you see so few foot locks in MMA
it's interesting right you see like so
few figure four foot locks because they
danger also for you to get hit right
yeah then sometimes when you do the foot
lock your face your arms are both around
the leg you can get I'm not defending
exactly
[Applause]